have you ever been playing
Counter-Strike and wondered what the
are all these chickens doing here
those chickens are up to Summit there
were exactly two chickens in the OG
Counter-Strike and then they mostly
disappeared from the series until the
release of Cs go and for whatever reason
they came back in droves on top of that
they weren't just funny little props
anymore they moved around and even
reacted to players which has caused some
issues for the pros
getting spammed down by jdc oh my God he
shot the chicken 10 seconds left robs
has to hold on to his gun chicken
blocking the door I've not seen that
before if that gets him killed but why
chickens and why let them interfere with
the game well it could just be an inside
joke from valve but no one really knows
many times how powerful the SG is on the
CT wow dude that's rude
yeah I agree